okay I want to talk about a sort of
bigger picture story that relates to
Brett Cavanaugh but is actually sort of
about Donald Trump and the Trump Russia
investigation and you might hear that
and say I don't really understand how
those things go together and I'll
explain to you how they go together
every single time that there is another
allegation against Brett Kavanaugh from
a sexual assault accuser or every time
that another Kavanaugh classmate says he
lied under oath about this or he lied
under oath about that every time we
figure out something else that Kavanaugh
just hasn't been upfront about right you
hear from more and more Republican
senators who say you know I really need
to think about whether this is somebody
that that that I can support I
immediately wonder why doesn't Trump
just pick somebody else and the reality
is that at any time Donald Trump could
call up Brett Kavanaugh and say listen I
need you to step aside it's become a
circus let me pick somebody else who
isn't going to have these issues because
if it's not Kavanaugh Trump can get
somebody else confirmed right that it's
not really an issue of whether Trump can
get anyone confirmed it's a question of
whether Kavanaugh can get confirmed but
Trump hasn't done that Trump has
continued to say or at least allow the
potential confirmation of Brett
Kavanaugh to go forward
I've up until now basically been of the
mindset that the reason Trump is
continuing with Kavanagh is Trump's
personality Trump doesn't want to be
seen as losing he would see it as a win
to get Brett Kavanaugh on the court and
he would see it as a loss if for
whatever reason he ended up having to
pick somebody else even though either
way you're gonna end up with a
conservative Supreme Court justice on
the court so increasingly I've started
to think it has to be more than just
that it can't just be that Trump simply
wants to win with Kavanagh because this
is taking a long time a lot of political
capital is being expended here what else
could it be and there's an entire other
storyline that could explain Trump's
desire for it to be not just any
conservatives about justice to a judge
to be put on the Supreme Court as a
justice
but specifically Cavanaugh and it
relates to Trump and Russia and Robert
Muller's investigation and that's what I
want to explain to you today and see
what you think about it if you are a
president who's being investigated for
possible very serious crimes that you've
committed potentially by a special
prosecutor Brett Kavanaugh is exactly
the type of guy that you would want as
the ninth vote on the Supreme Court why
well Cavanaugh has argued not only that
you can't indict a sitting president
they're actually a number of legal
experts who agree with that but that
presidents shouldn't even have to face
criminal prosecution or criminal
investigations while they are presidents
and that presidents don't even have to
follow laws that they deemed to be
unconstitutional there's a major piece
of case law around investigating
presidents which is US v Nixon from 1974
in the past Cavanaugh has questioned the
correctness of that decision many times
on the question of whether a sitting
president can even be subpoenaed to
answer questions again that something
Trump is dealing with right now the
point of view of someone who disagrees
with US v Nixon is very clear if you
think the 1974 Nixon case was decided
incorrectly as Cavanaugh has stated
you're probably going to rule if it came
before the Supreme Court that Donald
Trump cannot be subpoenaed to testify as
part of this investigation
if Trump ultimately wants to fire Robert
Mahler and that decision were to end up
before the Supreme Court if you're a
judge or justice like Cavanaugh and you
think that the 1974 Nixon case was
decided incorrectly you probably rule in
defending Donald Trump's firing of
Robert Muller if it were to take place
now defenders of Cavanaugh and Trump
will write in to me and they'll say well
yeah he has been critical of that 1974
decision but at
other points Cavanaugh has also said
that he thinks the decision was made
correctly I think without a doubt the
most recent and relevant statements that
Cavanaugh has made about that decision
are that he doesn't think it was the
right decision when during his
confirmation hearings Cavanaugh was
asked by Senator Kamel Harris whether he
had conversations about the Trump Russia
investigation with anybody at the law
firm of mark Kazu it's had been
defending representing Donald Trump in
that investigation
he gave non answers that's another
reason Trump may want Cavanaugh
specifically because Cavanaugh may
already have been involved in
discussions about the Trump Russia
Moeller investigation and one can can
even argue actually that Cavanaugh's
lying and unhinged sort of erratic out
of controlled demeanor during last
week's weeks hearings might also be part
of why Donald Trump wants him on the
court sort of an audition for it Trump
wants Kavanagh on the court because
quite frankly he wants an angry erratic
dogmatically loyal guy who believes in
almost totally unfettered presidential
power and he wants that person on the
court as soon as humanly possible so
that Trump can get back to interfering
with and getting in the way of Robert
Muller's investigation this means it's
not only incredibly important to block
Cavanaugh but we've got to take over as
many seats as possible in November
within those November midterms which are
now just over four weeks away because
not only is this a play to influence the
judiciary of the United States for
decades Kavanagh in his early 50s it's a
direct play to continue interfering with
the Trump Russia investigation which we
know has been one of Donald Trump's top
priorities for a very long time at this
point send me your thoughts could this
be why Trump is sticking with Cavanaugh
when pretty clearly at this point it
would probably be easier just to get
somebody else confirmed make sure you
follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
on Instagram
well at David Pakman behind the scenes
pictures of my temporary studio for the
week and much more quick break I will
interview economist Steve Kean coming up
next today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular nonfiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
jobs by David Graeber
which I listened to on blinka they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
Escom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month that's be Li NK
is t.com /pa k ma n